president biden having second thoughts
on ending an effective trump-era border
policy
only after democrats revolted and
started siding with republicans
revolting democrats
biden is reportedly thinking about
displaying and delaying his repeal of
title 42. which has blocked nearly 2
million people from entering the country
illegally republican governors are
trying to clean up with uh clean up this
mess by launching a border strike force
but maybe they're forgetting that biden
already has his own
does the president still have confidence
that the vice president can get to the
bottom
of root causes of migration he
absolutely does and and is grateful for
her work in doing exactly that why why
does he have confidence or should i
should i give you an update on a couple
of the things we've done
there is no update judge how what kind
of update that she found the root causes
it's worse than ever now well she did
it's a fair question didn't you hear
yeah it was about doing what we have
been doing every day what about space
and space how space connects all of us
the final frontier yeah
there is there is absolutely nothing
that she has found out about root causes
i mean she hasn't really been to the
border the real border of what's going
on and that's why you've got the
republican governors who are looking to
unveil their own strike force or
whatever they want to call it they want
to combat the gangs they want to share
intelligence they want to do what law
enforcement does and that is mutually
assist each other and and and you know
kudos to abbott and uh to desantis let's
start moving the border to those cities
that have no idea of what's going on at
the border and by the way those
democrats those 10 democrats senators
they're not doing it because all of a
sudden they feel like gee they're really
violating the law and we are
conspirators and and accessories so
they're violating the law they're doing
it because they know they're going to
get their butts voted out of office
because they are not supporting the
american people two good points there
geraldo the one that uh that the judge
mentioned about making the immigration
problem a visual one by by abbott
bringing the border on a road trip i
mean that's working that's grandstanding
what really brought the border to
people's attention and and where they
got it in a visceral way was drones and
the where you could actually see
the crossing all day long of the rio
grande and the but that was you know
that was never shown in other networks
well i i think the i think the picture
in the visual has gotten out and i do
believe that immigration will be a big
issue not the biggest not nearly the
biggest as i always say in inflation as
that that dubious distinction my problem
with title 42 is simple
we're saying now that the disease has
run its course essentially now the
hospitalizations are down people are not
dying uh you know the era of covet is
ending hence the no mask
if it's over it's over child 42 is a
health
provision to protect us from people
spreading the disease so why don't you
just call it what it is it is an
effective way to reduce the migration
the illegal migration of single males i
mean that's what it is why don't you
make it uh you know uh an ordinance or a
law or a rule uh but don't hide it under
the disguise of being a health related
ordinance call it uh whatever call it uh
you know single males go home or where's
mexico to help us single males go home
that's the e-club on any military base
but anyway look i assume you're going to
let me talk now i'd like to talk about
this of course so with title 42 i agree
with you like all these republicans
calling to keep title 42 going that is a
coward's way out listen you have to
tackle this problem legitimately and
using our government using power from
our government in that in that
manipulated way i'm never going to
support regardless if it benefits a
policy i want or not at the end of the
day what they should do is absolutely
let title 42 rescind and then every bit
of the problem hanging around democrats
next for the next two elections i come
from a town that's 78 hispanic inside
the city limits i actually understand
this problem what put the border on
people's minds is living in towns even
in georgia where it's a problem where my
sister's t-boned by an illegal immigrant
that never got a driver's license my
uncle's t-boned by an illegal immigrant
that never got a driver's license my
uncle has to pull a drunk immigrant out
of a car who just t-boned the lady that
plays the organ at our church i'm not
saying these are terrible people but you
can't come here
and live in the shadows in such a way
that you don't have the option to even
understand the laws in which you are
supposed to abide everyone's being
cheated to include the immigrants and
it's not just about single males when
you pile a classroom full of 20 kids
that have been here for two weeks and
can't speak our language or or there's
not enough teachers to get them through
then all the other kids are suffering
and those kids are suffering it's about
the the entirety of the problem and this
little cheap way of putting a band-aid
on a tourniquet problem should not be
what we allow our our elected
representatives i am proud of you for
taking that position but didn't you tell
me how safe your hometown was you don't
even lock your car my hometown is is two
hours from where i live now yeah i i
think that and it is i think it is safe
but that is undocumented migrants bring
down crime joey's house is safe because
he's armed to the teeth the guy has an
arsenal bigger than most malicious
bring down crime by having an influx of
people who don't even understand the law
in which in which crime is regulated an
influx of people who have not been
vetted and you don't know who among them
is the drunk truth and who may look like
even who they deserve
not against them the judge made a second
point surprising two good points from
the judges oh thank you greg you're
quite welcome uh she was talking about
how it really didn't change among the
democrats until there was political
fallout you always think about remember
the kids in cages didn't exist when uh
obama was in office but then they
existed with trump's in office and then
they didn't exist again when when abide
was office according to the media i
think it was cnn chris salisa described
this immigration crisis as a sneaky
a sneaky problem for this fault because
they haven't been watching it it kind of
just snuck up on them remember when you
said that fox news is like an early
warning system for democrats
how could you how could you miss it yes
but they're not missing it do you know
how you know when you have a to-do list
and then there's that one item that you
never really want to deal with so you
just copy it over to the next day
immigration has become that for the
administration they know it's their
biggest most difficult problem and every
day they're like oh maybe tomorrow we'll
work on that that's a good face uh a fan
mail friday question what's the thing on
your to-do list you keep pushing okay
well maybe we should use that yes
but when the democrats started bailing
on president biden then he had no choice
yeah because now he recognizes what you
were saying in terms of the politics
he's in this unpalatable position he
knows that he's got all these democrats
are going to start to move away usually
in a midterm year that happens if the
president's in trouble that happens in
the fall this is april yeah and so on
the merits they have to figure out a way
to deal with this there is a way you
could lift title 42 and actually do
something about the border that is also
an option but it's the last thing on the
to-do list yeah and could he ever get
bipartisan support ever does he try
i don't know
all the trust well they're trying to
throw off their hands all they say is
well republicans need to have an idea
like there's lots of ideas and they
don't like those ideas exactly codified
title 42 is an idea all right we got to
move on to the series hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else